no sponge look tonight funds listen I
can know what that would season tan
[ __ ] now she don't want all-stars but a
little elevation it's just lunch is this
little very important part of the money
exchange her story we're still like in
the vibe of a spine fit you know a
little richer I almost had a green
clutch but I was like build a stop stop
stop stop I don't want to know stuff on
a career as camp game so I was like no
camp today headed into this finale who
are we rooting for you know I'm to
Vangie girl I love Angie and she's my
girl I'm uh
I can literally cannot stop watching her
I want to see her every day of my life
okay so Monet didn't get the memo that
Vangie wasn't in the top four but hey
she's still soaking up her big win on
all-stars for that means they're not the
latest to be crowned anymore how has
life changed
we're cause we current framing on the
current framing my life isn't amazing
just so many great things on the horizon
I um I have a talk-show son will build a
series or it excited about voicing a
character on a Nick jr. card to another
main on the Carson theory but it's like
drag race is blowing my effing mind and
yeah just great things happening I'm
just real excited about it all busy can
we do some rapid fire about the season
we just watched yeah what was the quote
of the season for you
what does Mandy say when she was when
she was Brittany and I forgot what it
was or opulence of course uplands
you earn everything opulence you own
everything
Levante is there something in that
Brittany to challenge but I can't
remember it was really funny like thank
you Miss fangy I thanked myself yes yes
that's what it is that that thing worst
fashion moment of the season
Oh worth fashion I would have to say
worth fashion you are so shady eat eat
I'm not answering that question they all
look lovely beautiful gals all right
beautiful gal Franklin great gowns
beautiful gowns and then always the lip
sync moment of the season for you Oh
for me it has to be Brooklyn and Evie I
mean the contortionist of it all these
[ __ ] do Pilates because I could never
get my body to do anything remotely
close to what he did Incredibles
we had all the ladies ask questions down
the carpet tonight the question left for
you was soap what up question mark stock
up $100,000 [ __ ]
[Music]